now for going red - do I really have to
say that every [ __ ] time I'm skint
Bay impossible crazy it's a game that
you brothers have suggested about five
[ __ ] million times that the fact that
it's called the impossible quiz has been
a reason for me not wanting to play it
look at that
I was tired of my intro back in 2013
look who's back everybody the impossible
quiz the original impossible quest came
out ten years ago this year we'll all be
dead soon can't wait to play this one
yes slap me do oh how I missed you ten
years anniversary impossible quiz pants
we are back
of course I'm gonna beat this game and
it's gonna be easy why because some of
the greatest gamer on the planet
everyone knows this everyone ask anyone
on the street ask your mom who's the
best gamer first question you can play
along of course first question on the
first day of impossible Christmas my
true love gave to me hepatitis B damn
I'm good at this game
good who draped spaghetti over Scrooge's
chest the ghost of Christmas pasta the
ghost of Christmas present the ghost of
Christmas yet to come him what
okay the pasta it was surpassed well
what is this it's waving salt season's
greetings pepper people and abomination
season's greetings
this is easy oh [ __ ] find their dodgy
bulb I found it this is so easy
are you kidding me are you kidding me
right now I'm killing it I'm gonna beat
this game on first ride just watch me
what makes Rudolph's nose glow red fairy
dust santa's bum crumbs elf dandruff
years of alcohol abuse
just pick the most horrific answer and
you get it right every time you want you
ensign yeah hey what what am I doing
here
Jesus Oh Merry Christmas everybody
how do i dab I think that's the really
though that's what I got to do right
what I got to do
oh I just had to keep making him licking
it I know that shut up who wrote the
song silent night Franz Xaver Gruber
Cairo Joseph Moore a rather intelligent
orangutan dammit Joseph Moore oh look at
that I actually I actually came over to
give up wait this is a new question
I don't randomize it what is this oh
that's a great question
I'm bored then the true meaning of sweet
oh it's the sweet baby Jesus there I
found it okay what makes Rudolph nose it
was years of alcohol abuse and then you
got a licking I don't know why that was
an obvious to me Jebus okay who wrote
the song 12 the 12 days of Christmas
[Music]
someone from France
goddamnit I hope it's not a hundred
questions like last time Jesus okay on
the okay alright okay alright where are
you where are you there you are [ __ ]
what makes riddles knows years of
alcohol abuse
licky licky chill a [ __ ] 2013 pewdiepie
is back baby
Carol wrote that ill ill why the hell
did you make this game in flash I forgot
it was this one wasn't it yes Frank says
gee I be
gibble get blitz ya guy oh great
nice one thank you where does father
Christmas leave your present
[Laughter]
on the roof in a bear trap are you
kidding me I got them all wrong
come on oh god I got to do all this
sweet baby Jesus
[Music]
man I really fill in the holiday spirit
right about now okay what do you want
gee I give blegh
all right here we go
in your stockings what on the roof
I don't know then so now there's a
Christmas quiz how about a Halloween
special 2 spoopy damage stop
put a little sprouts okay
this is a tricky one I have to click
somewhere else write this it's a it's a
fake one all right whatever so now
there's a Christmas quiz how about too
late I can't be arsed remember what the
hell is it then advent calendar
chocolate death ball Tim so great thank
you
oh my god I'm already sick of this I
don't know there's a tricky one
it's just snake one but I click them all
[Music]
I clicked I too late I click to Spoony I
killed I can't be on I click that what
are you kidding me
how would you rate this quiz so far oh
yeah I already got it right once don't
say anything
not as good at the originals I hate you
okay it's almost too Christmasy mediocre
what the hell is the answer
Christmas tree on the roof in a bear
trap
what the hell I don't [ __ ] know in
your stockings then in your [ __ ]
I don't what else am I supposed to click
so dumb
mediocre huh I don't [ __ ] know what
that ace a Bobo oh my god
which one blinked I didn't see so dumb I
don't know I don't know I don't know I'm
gonna sit it out I'm gonna sit it out
[ __ ] me
okay that didn't work how would you rate
13 oh my god I had to click the start
great fantastic
Oh what it says there's something here
it's hidden underneath on the missus oh
no it's over here actually it says that
that was it where two pirates hide their
Christmas presents in a massive chest
and the bowels of the Kraken pirates
don't celebrate Christmas under a palm
tree in the bowels of the Kraken
[Music]
don't look at me like you knew the
answer cuz you didn't what did I pick I
picked this one and I picked this no I
picked this one in a massive chess
that's so lame under poultry then I
don't know stop asking me what what the
hell I don't know there must be a secret
there is a secret here somewhere and I
shall find it
today that I hit pirates don't celebrate
Christmas I hate this quiz why would
they do this to me I beat the first one
I got to do all this again
we're two pirates hi there Xmas one day
it's on the X everyone prepare for
takeoff what do i do what do I do
I am prepared what do I do oh my god
Oh what do I do here what do I do here
what do I do here what do I do here what
do I do here what do i what do I do here
what am I doing here
[Music]
great great you just hit it there
fantastic
what do I do I hate the time ones it's
like dude [ __ ] off alright another time
line Santa you're not Santa
you're not even Santa Oh Oh Satan Satan
I don't know what I did does that
okay wait skip skip okay I got it Satan
say - say say Todd
Noel Valentine Halloween ulid tied
Easter you're latina you're latina
dammit
Easter oh my god oh that's the keyboard
it's the keyboard it's the keyboard it's
the arrows it was the arrows Jane yes
I'm a genius
I'm a goddamn Einstein I'm a record
Morty 3000 what's the most popular
Christmas wine ass avignon Blanc you
know what a peanut what this game is out
of culture I don't know slippers
slappers tissues you can't wait tissues
but what is this name
skip hey I got another skip oh wow no
it's
did I do it I did it but then I miss the
goddamnit game
what is a Turlock a Turkish wizard
[Music]
goddamnit somewhere you can stuff a
turkey what does that mean
reindeer test they must be that great -
goddamn it let them get it
wait what oh god I'm dead
oh I'm dead oh [ __ ]
the 20th is time to open your presents
if you got any ok ok ok ok
[Music]
what do you mean hey what what hey okay
blue red it's working blue
Merry Christmas congratulations you did
it check out your presence on the
collection page back to menu wow it
would seem that they're impossible
Christmas wood would be really named
possible Christmas because it was easy
told you I told you Merry Christmas
everybody hope you have a great happy
holidays and all that stuff
credits to me for beating this game see
you next time everybody
pizza pie